man Tyrell about to come out here right  now that lady what's this what she's  doing yo Tyrell yo what up Lauren hey  man you want to play front hand back  here I don't know that game man it's  easy though all you got to do is stay  front hand in the backhand all right  front hands  bam I got you sucker  oh okay okay I see how it is no man come  on you know that that's funny backhand  huh it's still my move right I choose  backhand this time  real back hand  s  oh look I'm sorry but I ain't sorry you  know what I mean I mean you asked for it  I mean you literally asked for it  right hand what no why you wanna hit him  got it I figured it out front hand no  back